in the last video you learned about
gradient checking in this video I want
to share you some practical tips or some
notes on how to actually go about
implementing this for your neural
network first don't use graduating
training or me to debug so what I mean
is that computing D theta or procs eyes
all the values of ID is a very slow
computation so to implement gradient
descent use backprop to compute D theta
and just use back prop to compute the
derivative and as only when you're
debugging that you would compute this to
Mitchell as close to D theta but once
you've done that then you would turn off
the grant check and don't run this
during every iteration being a sentence
it's just much too slow second if the
never fails brag check look at the
components look at the individual
components to try to identify the bug so
what I mean by that is is the faith in
aprox is very far from DSA so what I
would do is look at the different values
of I to see which are the values of D
theta aprox they're really very
different than the values of D theta so
for example um if you find that the
values of theta or D theta they're very
far off all corresponding to D BL for
some layer or for some layers but the
components for DW are quite close right
remember different components of theta
correspond to different components of B
P and W but you find this is the case
then maybe you find that some the bug is
in how you're computing DP the
derivative respect to parameters B and
then similarly vice versa we find that
the values they're very far you know the
values from D theta aprox that are very
far from D theta and you find that all
those components came from GW or from GW
and certain layer then that might help
you hone in on the location of the bug
there doesn't always let you identify
the bug right away but sometimes it
helps you give you some guesses about
other where they track down the bug next
um when doing grad check remember your
regularization term if you're using
regularization so if your cost function
is J of theta equals 1 over m sum of
your losses
um and then plus this regularization
term right some of the hell of wll
Frobenius norm squared then this is the
definition of J and you should have that
D theta is gradients of J or respect to
theta
including the regularization term so
just remember to include that term next
Grouch egg doesn't work with dropouts
because in every iteration dropout is
randomly eliminating different subsets
or the fit in humans there isn't a easy
to compute cost function J the dropout
is doing gradient descent on it turns
out that dropout can be viewed as
optimizing some cost function J but its
cost function J is defined by summing
over all exponentially large subsets of
nodes they could eliminate in any
iteration so the cost function J is very
difficult to compute menu just sampling
the cost function every time you live in
a different random subset and military
use gravel so it's difficult to use grad
chair to double-check your computation
with dropouts so what I usually do is
implement grad check without dropout so
you if you want in set key prop in
dropout to be equal to 1.0 and then turn
on dropout and hope that my
implementation of dropout was correct
there are some other things you could do
like fix the pattern of nose dropped and
verify that grad check for that a
pattern of unis killed off is correct
but in practice I don't usually do that
so my recommendation is turn off dropout
use drag check to double-check that your
algorithm is at least correct without
dropout and then turn on dropout so
finally this is the subtlety it is not
impossible rarely happens with not
impossible that your implementation of
gradient descent is correct when W and B
are close to zero so at random
initialization but that as you run grain
descent and W and B become bigger maybe
your implementation of back prop is
correct only when W and B is close to 0
but it gives more inaccurate when W and
B become large so one thing you could do
I don't do this very often but one thing
you could do is run drag check your
randomness
elevation and then train the network for
a while so the wmb had some time to
wonder away from zero from the small
random initial values and then run drat
check again after you've trained for
some number of innovations so that's it
so gradient checking and congratulations
are coming to the end of this week's
materials in this week you learned about
how to set up your trained jab intersect
how to analyze bias and variance and
what things to do if you have high bias
and Siberians versus maybe high by 9
high variance you also saw how to apply
different forms of regularization like
l2 regularization and drop on your
neural network so some tricks for
speeding up the training video network
and then finally gradient checking so I
think you've seen a lot in this week and
you get to exercise all these ideas in
this week's program exercise so best of
luck exact and I look forward to seeing
you in the week 2 materials